many of you may have heard about the
rapid advances in artificial
intelligence possibly including the
incredibly realistic so-called deep
fakes those deep fakes are computer
generated video and audio often of real
people that are meant to look real but
are very much not real for this sunday
60 minutes bill whitaker discovered
firsthand how far the technology has
come just take a look
all it took was eight minutes of me
reading a script on camera for synthesia
to create my synthetic talking head
complete with my gestures head and mouth
movements another company dscript used
ai to create a synthetic version of my
voice this is bill woodacher's synthetic
voice with my cadence tenor and
syncopation
this is the result
the words you're hearing were never
spoken by the real bill into a
microphone or to a camera he merely
typed the words into a computer and they
come out of my mouth
it may look and sound a little rough
around the edges right now but as the
technology improves the possibilities of
spinning words and images out of thin
air are endless
i'm bill woodacher i'm bill whittaker
i'm bill woodaker wow
and
the head the eyebrows the mouth the way
it moves it's all synthetic i could be
lounging at the beach and say folks uh
you know i'm not going to come in today
but you can use my avatar to do the work
you could do that
maybe in a few years
don't tell me that
and bill whittaker the real bill
whittaker
are you sure i believe you are sure you
uh on the one hand i want to say isn't
that amazing but on the other hand i
want to say past the adult diapers
that's scary stuff
let's talk about those two realms of it
uh first the amazing part where house is
being used
i have seen a lot
in this long career that i've had but
this
is truly mind-blowing i mean it is i
mean what you saw there is sort of like
the cutting edge with this one you could
still tell that it was uh
an avatar that was made up but they with
just a few snippets of video a little
sample of my voice can make me say
or do
anything
now this company you know the company
we're working with synthesia they will
not do that they i have to give them
approval to have anything that my avatar
says yeah but the technology is there
for someone to take it and manipulate it
and make people say and do anything so
that could mean for example uh elon musk
has announced he's moving tesla to texas
that's real but a deep fake could fake
that news disrupting markets or you
could have a world leader kim jong-un
appearing to say an attack is imminent
somewhere what do you do is it real or
is it fake that's the scary part that's
the scary part and it's a big fear
the intelligence agencies the military
even big tech are all trying to figure
out how can we detect this how can we
say this is fake and this is real and
right now nobody knows the answer dude
right now they don't
even the people what about the people
who are putting it on they know how to
stop it don't they they can you're
talking lots of people i mean the people
who are doing it's got it's got
tremendous
benefits say you are
a ceo
and you have
employees all over the world
you can speak to your employees in hong
kong
in cantonese in rio de janeiro in
portuguese you can make it personal you
can say as the as the ceo
gail i really like the work you're doing
and you could make a personal message to
this to your employee
that's the good side the bad side what
you're saying can you imagine
politicians having their hands on the
ability to
make their opponent look bad yeah
exactly that's what i was thinking and
that's what i was thinking you were
talking about
those entities trying to detect it but
what about
those trying to use this technology is
that a concern when you were seeing how
impressive this was it's a real concern
it's a real concern as i say the um our
intelligence agencies and military
they're they're aware that this
there's going to be a an onslaught of
fake
of deep fake
videos and and audio
and
the companies are saying that perhaps
there'll be some way that they can put a
a a digital marker
a watermark so that you'll know that
this was an authentic piece of video i
mean and anything after the counter see
how it was manipulated but so far that
that has not happened video is the one
thing we we have that i think unites
people around some idea of a shared
truth if you see it you can believe it
if you hear it you can believe it this
undermines
all of that yeah our trust in authentic
videos trust in our own lives yeah uh
it's not just what they could create
it's the doubt that is cast on authentic
video and audio yeah
we're about to end it scares me it
really does it scares me happy for
hollywood but after that yeah if you're
if you're a high-end actor you get up in
the morning you'll never age you know
you can be 35 forever but for the rest
of us it's a great a lot of questions do
we want to be 35 forever
on tv baby
all right
bill thank you very much you can see his
full story on 60 minutes this sunday
right here on cbs